do you
hate spiders
[Music]
oh the babies come out of it
oh look at them their legs
their eyes and oh man they're
webs well it turns out
that they don't like you much either
imagine that you've stumbled
into the belly of the beast and now
you're trapped
in the sticky horrifying webs of
a giant spider just how strong is this
stuff
[Music]
do you have any chance of breaking free
or are you going to become the spider's
next meal this is what if
and here's what would happen if you got
caught in a giant spider web
it looks like you've gotten yourself
into a sticky situation
spider's webs are not something to take
lightly
especially if you're caught in one
each strand of spider silk is 1 000
times
thinner than a strand of human hair and
each strand of silk
is made up of thousands of nano strands
which are
10 to 20 millionths of a millimeter in
diameter
and they're very very strong
i know what you're thinking 1 000 times
thinner than hair
please
well laugh it up now because if we
extrapolate this information
to a human-sized spider a big enough web
could snag a jetliner talk about
ordering delivery
spiders use their silk for making webs
protecting their offspring and
as a way to escape predators and above
all
for catching and wrapping up their prey
orb webs contain several different kinds
of silk
and make webs that are strong and rigid
the silk is produced in different glands
and
has different characteristics depending
on what the spider needs for example if
the spider wants
some building material it will use its
major ampulet plant
for capturing food it would use its
flagella form silk gland to build the
trap
the spider then covers it with a sticky
glue-like coating
the glue is both viscous and elastic
and very very hard for food to escape
from
and i'm sorry to say that in this case
the food is you so
let's break this down on a scale of
spiderweb
to oh no i'm gonna be spider food
let's say you only got an arm stuck in a
massive web
well in this case you're very likely to
escape
this is because you can just cut your
arm loose
if both of your arms get stuck well we
hope you're flexible enough
to use your legs to separate at least
one hand from the web
it's also worth noting that now would be
a good time to lose your jacket
shoes and even your pants if they're
attached to the web
[Music]
you don't want to wait around and see
what's coming
but what if you weren't so lucky what if
you managed to get completely snagged
and the homeowner of this
web of death is lurking nearby
well you're not gonna like this next bit
of advice but
you gotta trust me on this i mean it's
not like you have many other options
you wanna make a fuss and attract the
spider over to you
wait don't go hear me out i know it
sounds insane but
it may just save your life if you're
wrapped up like a pig in a blanket
you'll want to wiggle scream and
essentially have a tantrum
now the spider is going to notice this
as their webs are basically built with
motion sensors your goal would be to
make yourself seem like you're
too big or too dangerous to be spider
food
and if the spider thinks that you're not
worth the trouble it'll cut you loose
this plan is based on research showing
that putting up a fuss
is the only way to escape scientists at
the university of longbeard
say that staying active is the best way
to get free from a spider's web
this is why we see some daring escape
artists
in the world of incense well that's
the plan anyway because it may backfire
if the spider thinks you look tasty well
it'll just wrap you up even more
this will completely restrict your
movement and
well things won't work out for you
you're either going to be eaten or die
of dehydration or
starvation from being in the web for so
long
thankfully we live in a world where
natural spider webs
aren't capable of catching a human being
that is
unless we artificially engineer some
or find ourselves with a sudden case of
giant spiders
but what if the rolls were reversed
what if you didn't get stuck in a
spider's web
but a spider got stuck in you
what if a spider crawled into your body
well that's a story for another
what if